Antoine Mariotti merci d'être avec nous
comment sont vécus par les populations
concernées ces référendums d'annexion et
qu'en est-il pour les populations russes
on vient d'en avoir un aperçu avec le
sujet de Johanna citrique c'est
évidemment partager et puis surtout il
est bien compliqué de savoir ce que
penser réellement l'ensemble de la
population russe parce qu'on voit bien
d'une part que la presse n'est plus du
tout libre que ce qui restait de
prestibre était écrasé à la faveur de
cette opération spéciale entre
guillemets qui est une guerre quand on
appelle ça un chat achat donc mais voilà
on a quand même un homme qui nous dit
c'est insupportable vous voyez qu'il le
dit rapidement partant il y en a
évidemment qui soutiennent aussi
beaucoup le président Poutine et puis il
y a le gros on ne le sait pas vraiment
et puis on interroge des gens à Moscou
mais dans la Russie profonde j'ai envie
de dire évidemment un petit peu
compliqué de le dire dans ces régions en
revanche qui ont été annexées donc des
régions qui sont ukrainiennes annexées
de facto et dans le droit russe
désormais dans quelques heures à partir
de 14h française
c'est référendum
si on regarde sur le papier on pourrait
dire tiens c'est un plébiscite comme le
disait Moscou 98% en faveur à deniet 98%
à lougans 93% des aporidja 87% rerson
bon ce sont des square un peu
soviétiques ou de ou de certaines
dictatures il faut quand même rappeler
d'une part que les autorités russes ont
tout fait pour que il y ait des votes
c'est à dire qu'il y a eu des policiers
qui ont patrouillé avec des
haut-parleurs dans dans les rues de ces
régions là il y a des urnes qui ont été
amenées directement chez des gens sous
bonne escort avec des robocops sur armés
autour ce qui est impressionne toujours
un petit peu donc déjà le contexte est
un petit peu particulier et en plus
évidemment côté ukrainien la plus de la
moitié de la population a quitté ces
régions donc il est impossible de savoir
réellement ce qui ce qui se passe mais
entre ceux qui sont partis et ceux qui
sont restés parce que c'est les hommes
qui sont restés aujourd'hui vont être
mobilisables par l'armée russe pour se
battre finalement contre leur propre
pays l'Ukraine donc on peut imaginer
évidemment que ça les enthousiasmes pas
plus que ça oui on n'a pas vu de grand
enthousiasme dans les rêves on annonce
un discours fleuve cet après-midi du
président russe Vladimir Poutine face
aux difficultés militaires actuelles sur
le terrain a besoin de présenter des
victoires oui c'est un écran de fumée
finalement parce qu'on voit bien que
depuis début septembre il n'a plus du
tout la main militairement la Russie a
perdu un grand nombre de villes reculé
en Ukraine il faut se rappeler que selon
les premières estimations de la CIA
notamment expliqué par son directeur il
pensait prendre Kiev en une semaine en
février dernier on est aujourd'hui le 30
septembre et même là où il s'était
replié dans certaines régions du Nord de
l'Est et bien ils ont fortement reculé
cette avancée ukrainienne elle se
poursuit en ce moment même il y a eu
trois nouvelles villes qui ont été
prises ces derniers jours il y en a une
autre qui est complètement encerclée et
qui est aussi un eu ferroviaire
extrêmement important pour les Russes
d'un point de vue logistique pour
acheminer et des hommes et des armes sur
le front donc ça ne va pas bien du tout
militairement donc la seule manière
finalement de faire grand écran de fumée
pour Vladimir Poutine c'était de
précipiter ces référendum qui étaient
prévus pour bien plus tard pour le mois
de novembre pour pouvoir dire bah voilà
vous voyez ces populations et nous
attendaient on les libère des nazis donc
maintenant elles sont indépendantes
depuis hier aux yeux du droit russe
uniquement ces quatre régions sont
indépendantes de l'ont été hier deux
autres l'été depuis le mois de février
et à partir de 14h elles seront
complètement intégrées dans le giron de
la Fédération de Russie donc encore une
fois c'est un écran de fumée sauf que la
fumée elle se dissipe et que dès demain
on va reparler de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain et sur le terrain et bien pour
l'instant
Vladimir Poutine n'a pas du tout la main
alors une dernière chose c'est qu'il a
dit désormais et bien que c'était son
territoire et s'il y avait une attaque
c'était une menace pour l'existence même
de la Russie qui était prêt à utiliser
des armes nucléaires ou est-ce qu'il
dira finalement bah vous voyez on a
gagné on a on a libéré ces territoires
maintenant on peut s'arrêter là c'est
pas dans le sens de ce qu'ils disent
pour l'instant mais on verra bien merci
beaucoup Antoine Mariotti pour votre
décryptage Merci à VOUS premier